we can make demands of our leaders but
the end of the day we can only be
responsible for ourselves like we can't
change our leaders when we can we can
vote them in and out or we can or we can
you know choose to get a different job
somewhere but we can't physically
actually changed the way that they're
gonna do business or how they see the
world you know no number of anonymously
sent books is going to solve that
problem but we can change ourselves and
you know when I hear people talking
about the system is broken
there's no mythical system it's us it's
a it's a our society is a collection of
individuals and and whatever the the
balance of behavior is from those
individuals is that is the system you
get and so it starts at home
it starts with us and so we want to
change the system this this this
elephant the only way to eat an elephant
is one mouthful at a time and so I think
we need to set ourselves on a course to
become better listeners ourselves and
there's a difference between listening
and hearing you know hearing is
understanding the words that are said to
you listening is trying to get to the
meaning of the words that are said to
you with an appreciation that sometimes
people say the wrong thing they say what
they're trying to say badly sometimes
emotions are involved sometimes they get
flustered and it's not for us to take
their words personally or even to even
pick a part but to rather try and show
up with curiosity to really understand
the meaning what I'm describing is
empathy we show up with empathy that's
that's all this is and we and to look
past the the the the superficial I've
heard it now you know which is you know
talking about some of the anger like if
they weren't angry then we'd probably
get more that this would be more
productive well do you understand while
they're angry do you let's go to the
root that's what listening is it was
Martin Luther King who said riots or the
language of the unheard remember we've
all know what it feels like to feel
heard to feel heard and the end to what
listening is it's the practice it's the
practice that another person will feel
hurt
[Music]
you